هنا في حاره الصوف في احدى ضواحي منطقه
وسط البلد في العاصمه القاهره تعكس ملامح
وجوه ابناء الجاليه السودانيه علامات حزن
واسى العيون تتوجه لشاشات التلفاز
والهواتف النقاله لمتابعه اخبار
الاشتباكات الداميه في السودان والحديث لا
يتوقف عن مجريات القتل والخراب والله
وقفوا حرف الدنيا رمضان يعني في حد في
رمضان بحارب يوقف حرب الناس دي مساكين ما
فيش كهرباء ما فيش مويه يعني احنا ما
واقفين مع الجيش ولا واقفين مع حماتي نحن
عايزين نحد اللحم السودان والسودان يد
واحده اغلب من التقيناهم لم يخفوا حزنهم
وغضبهم الجميع يحاول ان يتواصل مع الاهل
والاقارب للاطمئنان على سلامتهم
يعني مش عايزين مش قادرين يعني ما قادرين
ينوم حتى بس ربنا يكون في عونه ان شاء
الله يا رب الكثيرون عبروا عن املهم في ان
تنجح المناشدات والمحاولات العربيه
والدوليه للوصول الى وقف لاطلاق النار
والحد من نزيف الدماء نتمنى من اخواننا
العرب المنطقه الجاليه العربيه كل ما
يجفهم معانا في كل شيء ان شاء الله يا رب
العالمين نوضح كل المجتمع الدولي
والاقليمي
تقف وقفه واحده اتجاه خروج من الازمه
الحاليه حاليا قاعد في الخرطوم الاحداث
وتداعياتها اثرت على مجموعات كبيره من
السودانيين والمصريين العاملين في مجالات
النقد البري بين البلدين شغل بتاعنا الضرر
من 3 ايام بالضبط او من اربع ايام الوضع
اختلف كان مثلا ومعايا عربيه ومعايا واحد
صاحبي معي عربيه بنشيل شغل بنودي شغل
الشغل من العادم بقى له اربع ايام عدد
ابناء الجاليه السودانيه في مصر يتراوح ما
بين خمسه الى ثمانيه ملايين نسمه رقم مرشح
للزياده في حال استمرار تدهور الاوضاع
السياسيه والامنيه والاقتصاديه احمد عثمان
العربيه القاهره
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات